It gets every single ounce of the delicious goodness that is
SCP Containment Breach.
Now... Hello, hi.
Welcome back to SCP Containment Breach
and welcome back to the newly updated version of it.
This is version 1.3.7,
which if you've been following, I believe the last time I played this was probably either version 1.1...
or version 1.2...
or maybe even 1.0.
So it's been a long, long time since I played this game
and it's uh.. it's been comfortably a while since I've done it.
So, hopefully you guys can see...
me, and everything that's going on.
So welcome. Good morning everybody. How are you doing?
Welcome to SCP Containment Breach, hope you guys are doin' a wonderful time.
This is live in case you were wondering, yes I can see your chat right there.
Yes, it's started a little bit earlier than the scheduled time I meant to get this out a little earlier;
but, I had some technical difficulties, and also I was warming up my voice because
if you were watching most recent Mortem for some reason my voice has been more fragile lately,
and uh, it's been a little bit tender.
So I'm getting back into the swing of things.
And I'm gonna be starting out with SCP Containment Breach and we're going to be going in very short order.
But I'm going to be starting the actual game in about
seven minutes or six minutes
as soon as it hits 10:30.
That's when I'm actually gonna be getting into the game
So in the mean time just welcome, how you doing?
If you've got questions for me please type them in the chat below.
I will try to answer them as best I can even though they're going -
holy-hell fast.
So if you guys are there, let me see you talk!
Come on, give it to me!
I'm right here!
Come on! Do it I'm here!
Gimme' something!
All I see is a bunch of "Hey" and "Hi."
So, hello everybody.
Hi hi hi hi- Oh My God.
Oh my God. Is this all you got?!
HUH?
IS THIS ALL THE CHAT YOU GOT?
IS THIS REALLY IT?!
COME ON, LAY IT ON ME!
You gotta have more than this here!
Ah yeah, that's better!
That's more like it!
Yeah- OH? You like Mortem? Oh good,
it was a little- it was a little jankie.
That's definitely to be sure. But uh...
Hopefully
Hopefully it'll get better because I like the hide-and-seek aspect of it.
It was just a bit.. little bit too constrained by
the faulty doors to be a 100%.
But this game...
This game is not constrained by faulty doors,
unless the faulty doors are there to screw you over;
Which often times they are.
Make a dick joke?
I don't wanna make a dick joke.
Yeah, Slow-Mode unfortunately
I know you guys are here and you're chatting up a storm
but Slow-Mode is the only way that we
can get some semblance of order here
And also prevent a little bit of spam, so...
Hopefully you guys can
put up with that for the time being.
I think it's only 30 seconds so,
if you need to say things within 30 seconds
man...
You guys are going way faster than I am, but,
I'm gonna join in here.
I'ma say- hang on
(in chat)
"Hello!
It's me
it's me guys"
I said hi.
Even though it's gone immediately, it's gone up and out of here.
So,
anyway, just 5 more minutes so
if you've got questions for me
write out in full complete sentences
what your questions are even though they're going soooo fast...
Yeah, I know- oh there's my message!
Oh man..
Tha- even that was delayed.
Holy hell!
Yeah...
Thank you, thank you so much I think I saw that
that was either I love your videos or
I fucking hate your videos.
I can't tell which one that was actually that.
But I'm going to assume
that no matter what you guys said I'm gonna thank you none the less,
because I appreciate that.
Oh, yeah this is the Vid-con...
Last years Vid-con shirt, so uh.
I tore the sleeves off to make way for my impressive musculature.
Which, is not as impressive as it used to be
but hopefully it'll get there again. Because..
I've found that the most enjoyable thing that I could be doing is trampolining.
And, and...
That may sound silly
but if you have ever gone to a s - like a - uh, SkyZone I think it's called.
I'm not promoting SkyZone, there's a lot of competitors.
In fact I've actually never been to a Sky Zone
I've been to a lot of the other versions
because every time I've gone to a SkyZone they've been closed
or they've turned me away at the door.
So, uh.. Go to anywhere else but SkyZone.
Anyway, but uh..
So, it's a trampoline gym
that just has a bunch of trampolines in the floor
and you bounce from bounce
and then you got obstacle courses
and cool bullshit like that.
It's super fun!
I like it. So I'ma be uh,
I'ma be doin' that.
and then I'm gonna be getting back
into rock climbing again
because that was something I fell out of that was really fun.
Uh, its just been super busy this
past time trying to prep for the show.
Yeah.
But anyway,
thanks again everybody, and uh..
Oh, Maxlavine says,
"Are you going to be doing the game all in one sitting..
..or starting up a series for this after the stream?"
Uh, good question.
I would like to do
A new series for this game if it so calls for that
I just thought I'd do a
Livestream to kinda to get into it.
Because there's so many new things in the game
that I'm not a 100% sure what I should do
or what I shouldn't do.
Uhm,
Let's see, Drako128408 says:
"Love you Mark, you're damn awesome,
keep doing your beautiful work..
..you amazing man."
Aw, thank you so much.
I really do appreciate that.
So I'ma be trying to do that as best as I can.
And then uh..
Then hopefully, hopefully.
I'll have something more to show for it later.
and then uh, maybe we'll have a series at the end of the day.
..uh..
And I dunno, I-I-It's really weird, because considering SCP Containment Breach -
is one of my -
longer running series, I think it's been overtaken by
Subnautica recently, but it is definitely one of my longer running series with -
Uhm...
How many- how many goddamn videos of -
that did I play? Cause' I played it for years, because -
it updated all the time in the initial phase.
And I still say, to this day I still say -
Gosh-darnit you guys -
at Undertow Games -
charge money for it.
It's so good!
You've put so much work into it!
I mean...
I know it's been free this whole time but you really...
Oh man.. Woah..
Ho- holy crap.
Hang on guys, woah, woah, woah.
Alright, okay.
There's a lot of messages here queued up.
So first up:
Uh.
PVPHacker says,
"I've been watching you since 3 million."
Thank you guys so much for
Uh, being here with me so long..
Joeydog, "High-five Mark,
"Top of the morning to ya!"
Jason Warley says,
"You are amazing and you inspire me everyday."
Uhm,
I-I- this is the new Super-Chat feature that they put in
Uhh...
That I-I I actually had no idea how it- how it even worked
But, anyway thank you so much, Jason Warley for...
Uhhh....
For being here and, and
watching the videos, and I really appreciate it, for what it is
And then IsaiahAngleMark says,
"Thank you Mark, for the years I've been subscribed to..
..you, you helped me through a lot of my depression."
I'm really happy to help you guys out and I'm-
well-I-mean-
In a way that sounds weird for me to say like..
I'm happy to help you guys out, I'm happy just to make videos every day and be here with you guys so...
Uhh... I just wanted to say how important that is to me.
And uh,
being here with you guys for this adventure.
And it's almost time to start, yeah- forty eight videos.
Forty eight videos.
Technically..
*giggle*
Fifty-three if you count
-there was, a long time ago
Uh.. There was a
there was a My Little Pony Mod for SCP Containment Breach that I played.
Uhm, I did a 5 episode series on that.
And uh,
that was a very controversial series 'cause I am not..
a brony or anything to that sort but uh..
Man.
People were all up in arms about me playing a
My Little Pony mod of it, I just thought it'd be funny
to see these
like, these horrifying things in a-
in a- in a pony world.
But if you count those, it's 53 videos
but if you don't count those which I'm totally...
like, you're totally okay with it, 'cause it's
in a completely separate playlist
that does exist though.
Alright.
And then uh...
Hayden Zammit says,
"Hey Mark, I love you so much can you read this out I love you so much."
Well I just did that, so thanks again.
Thanks uh, thanks Hayden.
And uh,
Jessie Loma says,
"Mark man, I've been watching you since the early days..
..but I always miss your livestreams
'cause I'm in Australia."
Well you made it to this one, so I really do appreciate it!
GlamorInGaming said,
"Thank you for being here through the dark times, I love you Mark."
And uh, JayJayKim,
"If you scream, marry me."
Well get ready, because I'm pretty sure this game is gonna cause me to scream involuntarily
And then uh, Bethany Thomas says,
"Hi, I get so excited when I see your livestreams."
So!
With that being said, I'm not gonna let anything else get
in the way of it, we're about to start a new game.
And uh, is that a good map seed that I like..
'Cause you get random map seeds now
And I don't know if they're actually gonna
mmmake any differ- LARRY
That seems like a very dangerous one!
I'm also gonna put it on Euclid.
So I'ma call this one Markimoo.
Alri- no I'm gonna call this one Larry.
This one's Larry, Larry.
Lotsa' Larry.
I'm assuming that I'm gonna be...
involved with Larry a lot.
No intro sequence 'cause we've already seen that.
It hasn't changed, I've already checked it out.
So, yeah.
Uh-oh!
Not armesh?
Did it cra- oh ah well that crashed
well that's good, I thought they worked out the bugs to this
one but apparently not, lemme try that again.
Maybe Larry Larry isn't the best one to have..
Hang on, gimme ah...
Gimme a hot second here.
Gettin' it back up.
Yeah, like I said uh, the gum-
the gum?
The game
oddly enough has still a few bugs to work out.
Let's see, TMoneyGaming says:
Uh, "Mark you're my inspiration to game, and have fun with content creation..
..strive to do good in the world, keep it up and looking forward to your next charity livestream!"
Which is coming, we are doing one this month, we just gotta figure out when we can do that.
Uh, Memoriana said,
"I fell in love with the new Subnautica series,
but I still don't understand your view of the ocean."
Uh, understand it? What's to understand, it's terrifying.
That's really all there really is to understand about it!
Let's see
"Hello Mark, where did Chica's name come from, is it from FNAF?"
Oddly enough, no.
Uh, Chica- it's just more of a coincidental thing
because her- her name before I got her was Sephora
and so I changed her name because I didn't want
to be calling out a brand of makeup
as good or bad as it may be
but uh, I just wanted to do that because it was important that I-
I changed that for me and that I wanted to name her so Chica.
It's important when you name a dog.. The end of the name..
..be the same, the beginning is not entirely important, but uh.
It's really the end of the name that they respond to,
so it's very important.
Amanda- Jay says:
"Any tour news you can talk about, I got my Darkiplier shirt and it fits amazing!"
Thank you so much for buying that, I'm glad you got that
that shipped out in good timely order.
Uhh, no tour news yet
I will..
let you guys know. We're still
looking at the beginning of June.
Uh, we just don't know the specific dates yet
Let's see...
Uhh, Jinyu says,
"Working on an animation, it's best I can do for repaying..
Uhhh...
..to repay for cheering me up in the hospital."
Aw...
Hope you're doing better!
Thanks so much for making a..
Uhhh. A uhh.. A uh... Uhm..
A uhhh, an animation for me
FoxIsPlaceless says,
"Thank you Mark."
Aurora Jankin says,
"Thank you for being you, Mark, it's so funny to..
..watch Subnautica, and because my name is Aurora..
..so you can do me a favor and say 'Hello Aurora!' "
Okay, hello Aurora, how are you goin'?
Ashley Warez says,
"I always admired you Mark, not just for your looks but..
..to your personality and moral and hope..
..to follow your example, love you much."
Okay I'll get to these messages very soon,
there are a ton of 'em.
But I wanna get back into the game
and make sure that this actually works so..
I'ma call this one Markimoo and hopefully..
..Larry isn't gonna..
..destroy me..
Come on now!
Aww, what is goin' on?!
It worked, I just loaded this game up!
I literally just loaded this game up and it worked fine.
Alllright, well
hang on one second, I'm gonna be right there.
I'm not gonna give up on this,
we're gonna get this definitely.
'Cause so long as I'm here
I di- I'ma try to load up the game that I did
I know for a fact works.
Because if I can get that
Then I'm definitely gonna get that.
Oh my goodness,
there's so many um...
I didn't realize that so many people would be using the Super-Chat function.
Oh...
Well that's a little disconcerting
This place will burn, that's... not a good sign.
Oh, frick I didn't save the game.
Let me try one more time.
Uhhh...Jeffrey...
Blap?
Damn it! Ok, let me try umm..
I can try to update the game.
'Cause there's an option to update the game right before it goes.
So let me just try to update it and while it's updating
I'm gonna try to read more of these messages because there's so many of them.
I did not-I did not even think that there was going to be that many messages;
but, thank you guys so much. I'ma try to read 'em as best I can right here...
I've got another way to do it.
Let's see...
Oh, many of these.
Oh-kay
Heh
Uh, uh, JentryAButler says,
"Please don't die this time."
No promises, can't even begin to
promise that one, because I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna die literally non-stop, no-matter what I do.
Tory Ryan says,
"I've been here since 2 million, you've helped me daily..."
Uhh, oh man, there's a- there's a
very personal story in there and I
don't want to read it out loud to you guys, but
but I just wanna say I hope you're doing- ...
okay now and umm...
I'm glad that my videos could give you
a laugh when you need it the most.
So that's- that's uh..
I'm really happy that I could help in whatever way.
Uh, yeah.
So, um.
Let's see...
Corey Waganer said,
"Your SCP videos have always been one
of my favorites, and this new feature..
..must be the new-spangled
thing to be competitive to Twitch."
Yeah, I suppose it is, YouTube
wants to be a little bit more uh...
.. more involved in it.
Yeah, so thank you guys so much
for being a part of this, and uh..
yeah, it really- it really does mean a lot
that you guys are here on this stream
and I will be..
I'll be there soon!
It's almost done downloading the
update and I'm gonna get there.
In just- in just a gosh-darn second.
Uh Joseph Welock says:
"Hey Mark I love your videos..
..and I hope you keep inspiring people to do happy..
..to be happy and do great things."
Thank you so much
Uh...
Mitchel Rolling says,
"3:34 AM and I'm pumped!..
You're an inspiration to many, love your work dude."
How many people are watching from international right now?
If you're- if you're outside of the U.S. even if you're in Canada or something;
like, say so in chat,
because I really do wanna know, like, how many people are actually
out and about.
I'm assuming that's from like Australia or something.
Because..
Ho man, there are so many people around here so...
Man it-it-it's a darn shame because
even with Super-Chat enabled there's so many messages
that it's really hard to get to all of 'em.
Uh, SpicyBrownieMix101 said,
"You really inspired me, I know it's not much but I hope it helps."
Aww thank you so much!
Uh...
Jay-whaaaeyy okay...
There we go.
Uh, JaimanTolly said,
"This Super-Chat feature's awesome..
*chuckle*
..It allows anyone with money to be seen..
..Anyway Mark, when will you come to Canada? Specifically Toronto?"
Uh,
I will...
I will think about doing a tour...
In Canada after we do the initial run
In the U.S. because what I wanna do is
I want to be
Here in the... In the uh... In the U.S.
in the beginning just so we can
plan out and do a better stream.
Uh, initially and THEN later on
we'll go out and move on into Canada
and I see tons of people are saying Canada,
Uh Germany, Puerto Rico, - I saw that - Sweden
I saw a LOT of people from Australia,
France, Scotland, Greece, - Greece? Wow - uh..
more Puerto Rico, Denmark, EGYPT?
Hell yeah!
And then India,
Norway,
Las Vegas.
Yeah that's outside of the U.S. practically.
Yeah, pretty much.
I'm gonna assume that that's not part of the U.S.
Alright.
So I'ma try this again. It's done updating.
If this can work...
Let's see, Ben Davies,
"Will you do a full play-through of Full Throttle: Remastered?"
I don't even know what that is...
What is that?
What is Full Throttle: Remastered?
*static of game* Woah *more static*
Alright, hang on let's try this one more time.
If this works I'm gonna be VERY happy.
Okay, we'll call this one uhh... Billy
Put it on Euclid...
Theeeeeen..
GO!
*BRUM* Ohhhhhhhhh it didn't!
It was about to hang up there!
It was about to freeze but I think we got it!
I think we got it this time! *ba-ding*
Oh, hell yeah.
*seductively* Oh, Hell Yeah!
Ohh! HELL yeah!
Okay.
So I'll be back with you guys, reading messages
in just a bit; if I DIE, I'ma read a few more messages
in-between each time but..
We'll see how this goes in just the immediate time!
*clicks on paper*
Alright, D-9341...
Oh yeah, that's what it always is anyway.
W-hey..
Hello.
So this intro. sequence shouldn't be any different than what it originally was
(silence as creepy music plays in the background)
Oh?
Usually they let me out by now...
(stip-steps)
Am I just gonna be stuck in here forever?
Until the day I die?
Any minute now!
Oh there we go.
Hi!
Guard outside cell:
"Control, this is Agent Halsling."
Guard:
"I need a request to open up cell 3-1-1."
Okay
Control:
"Copy that."
(door sliding sounds)
Hello!
Guard:
"They've got some work for ya, do me a favor, and step out of your cell."
Alright, I'll do ya that favor.
Guard:
"Just follow me. Oh, and by the way,
we're authorized to kill any disobedient test-subjects;
so, don't try anything stupid."
Oh yeah no yeah, like take your gun and shoot you in the back?
I guess I won't need to worry about that very soon,
you're gonna get shot up as it is.
Intercom:
"Attention: Sergeant, Valbasin, please report to:
Firing Range, Foxtrot."
Guard 1:
"Man I'm hungry, hey, today's Pizza Day
down at the cafeteria right?"
Guard 2:
"Uhm, actually I think it's tuna casserole."
Guard 1:
"Oh. Godammit!"
"Now my day's ruined!
Guard 1:
The only reason I still come here is for the pizza.
I don't know what it is about that pizza,
Guard 1:
but it's delicious.
Tuna casserole, on the other hand,
Guard 1:
is a disgusting abomination and it should be locked up in here with the rest of these freaks!"
Guard 2:
"Uhhh... Oookaaay...?"
*Mark giggles*
Well then!
Alright! Okay!
Guard:
"Well, we're here, just get in there and follow all the instructions
and uhh... you'll PROBABLY be fine."
*delightfully*
Okay, thank you!
Thank you, sir!
Thank you for the lovely introduction.
I'm glad that you're here with me,
through this time,
forever and ever.
Alright.
So anyway, at least it's working.
Intercom:
"All Class-D personnel-"
*Mark interrupts*
Oh, the memories.
God I-I'm like flooded with memories right now
I-I, like I first played this game so long ago.
Before these guys were even like,
fully modeled or anything.
It may not have even-
Intercom:
"Please approach SCP-173.."
Like
Intercom:
"..for testing."
Like it used to start just right there.
Intercom:
"Uhh... There seems to be a problem
with the door control system."
Don't do it!
*Jumbled voices, guard threatens Markimoo*
Intercom:
"Please maintain direct eye-contact with SCP-173 and-"
(loud ringing)
Guard:
"Oh shit...
Oh shit, oh shit!" *gunshots*
Well.
Everything's gone all kinds o' bad!
So maybe we should get outta here.
Okay. So,
Uh, in this mode...
Oh...
Hello.
Press F5 to save,
Okay I did it.
Oh, uh-oh.
Oh, they're smart.
Ohhhh it's a tutorial!
Oh, they're trying to teach me how to play this.
Oh I see how it's going.
But too bad for them. I already know how to play!
Is he down there?
Oh he's down there, isn't he?
Oh... Eghhh...
Man they made this a lot more creepy than it used to be!
Okay is he here?
(Roar in the background)
Yee...
Okay
*loud static noise*
I'm sorry.
Intercom:
"Attention: All personnel report too:
*inaudible static*
Intercom:
Immediately."
Okay
Didn't quite catch that message there.
If you could repeat it for me that'd be great.
Ohh noooo....
Ohh nooOO...
*Sexy Mark voice*
Oooohhhh...
They've- *interrupted by creepy sound*
Excuse you!
I don't know what happened over there; but, shut the fuck up, I'm tryin'a concentrate!
Alrighty then!
Oh good!
I can get a keycard at least, to start off the bat.
And this cup
I'll need that cup actually.
It may not seem like a whole lot right now.
But I am gonna need that eventually.
Be-a-cu-ause
There is some sort of liquid dispenser.
I don't know what it does fully but,
let's see uhh...
"Endothermic Pack-Based Predators"
Oh yeah, that's not good.
"Highly permeable with moisture and translucent-"
Oh I know what that is! That's the stuff in the basement.
If I'm not mistaken,
Is this the series of hallways?
"Recursive Spacial Phenomenon"
Yay!
I got an achievement!
Oh good! I'm glad they have that.
Ehhh...
Oh-boy. Okay. Alright then.
Well that's a thing
I don't need to worry about that I-
*weird and creepy noise*
Okay, alright then, movin' on!!!
Movin' on!!!!!
Ugh.
Okay what do you guys think, should I go left or right?
Got a choice here, I need a solid answer: Left or Right.
Left or Right.
I know it's probably going to be split right down the middle of left or right.
But I just want to know what the balance between people voting left and people BOING right is.
Yep
Okay, I'm getting a lot of in-between-ers.
Okay, I'm seeing predominately more left then I am right.
Okay
Now it's more right then it is left.. okay
I dunno which one you want. So I'm just gonna
eeny-meeny-miny-moe this.
Eeny-meeny-miny-mo, catch a tiger by the toe,
*increasingly panicked*
if he hollers let him go...
Alright, I'll go left, you guys seem to like left.
Fine.
Ooo...
I dunno what this- Hey!
*Distant girl's scream*
Again! What did I say about shuttin' fuck up?
Concentrating!
You don't allow me to concentrate I'm 'onna get killed!
(Loud screeching door)
Alright. So I, whoa..
I hear... Oh!
*distant scream of pain*
*distant screams*
Oh...
I'ma... I'ma stop telling them to shu'-da fuck up 'cause...
Okay, so...
So Bill Bally...
Billiba Lolly.
Oh... Hey...
How's it going?
That's... That's a bad oozy... Ay!
Forgot about that one.
Alrighty then.
Hello?
Are you okay?
Do you need medical assistance?
Alrighty then.
Alright since... Uhy!
Since you guys voted left last time, I gonna vote
right this time.
Alrighty then
Oh. Keycard. Is this good enough?
Nah.
Not high enough clearance.
There's also some low frame-rate around that one.
D'aaeeeeeyyyy..
You can't scare me with easy scares like that.
I already know my shit around here.
Damn it. I need higher security clearance.
Level 1 doesn't get you anywhere in this game.
Like it barely gets you into the most low-end of all things...
Alright, I'ma go left this time.
Oh.. Is this.. Ah... It's a checkpoint. But I don't think...
I don't think Level 1 gets you through this. I'm pretty sure.
Yeah... You need...
ugh..
*man crying*
You...
*crying continues*
Are y-you, uh...
You okay?
whoa, whoa, Whoa, Whoa, WHOA!
Something just pulled my vision over there.
Okay, I don't know what it was, but I don't like it.
Okay. I don't see anyone crying like a little baby over there, so I'm gonna go the other way.
Alright,
what do we got here?
Goddammit. Stop doing that.
It just whippin' my vision around, and I know for a fact that's an SCP.
That's not just the... the mouse being all janky like that.
That's a goddamn SCP.
Okay.
Oh no, I'm not goin' in that air-lock.
No, thank you.
No, no. Oh wait. I have to go in that air-lock.
Shit...
Alright.
Here we go.
Hello?
Oh hi. You're in there. I know you are.
Oh God. Where is it?
Where is it?
Oh God, I forgot about that!
It's over there!
Okay.
Alright.
Don't kill me.
Ahhh. Don't kill me.
Don't kill me. (x5)
Okay.
Where are you?
Ah, that's a problem.
Is this far enough?
Hi.
*breathy*
harner...
h
I almost forgot about the harner breathing.
Oh boy.
That's bad.
Alright.
I forgot about that one.
It's been so long since I played this. The checkpoint system is all wonky-woo.
Eee.
Oh boy.
Ohhh boy!
Alright. Whoa!
Good!
I don't wanna go down there yet!
Ahh fuck...
I don't wanna go down the basement yet.
I don't think I have everything I need up here because I believe...
Oh no.
What is that?
Why's it getting black in there?!
Larry?
Larry?!
Don't do it, Larry.
Larry?
Well... I don't like that.
Larruh.....
Ayyyyyyeee. Okay.
Ah. Fuck!
I'ma try my on this one.
Oh boy.
Oh.
I can't save the game.
In this one, I can't save it until...
I use the key card in the thing.
Ohhh boy.
Eh eh eh... okay.
Goddammit. It's just another elevator.
Ohhh. There's a dead guy in that one.
That... That awfully..
*loud static*
AYYY!
*distorted static talking*
I don't like that.
*pbbbht*
Man. There's a lotta... There's a lotta... There's a lotta...
lotta lotta scary babies in chat here right?
I didn''t want to call you stright up cowards or nothing but...
There's a lotta scary babies. That're just like..
Every time there's something...
Run! Run Mark! Run!
Run away!
I know.
I know how you be.
Don't worry. I'm here to guide you through this experience.
Start to fini... Man, there are so many checkpoint... Whooooooaaaaaa.
I found the architect appearently.
Hello!!!
Hi buddy.
How ya doin' there?
Oh, you're weird.
Okay. Alright then.
You have a good one.
You have a good-in'.
Yeah, you have good now. You have good and take good.
Take good and have it.
Have good to take it.
Take good wherever you go and have that.
Just have it... Oh
Why is it weirdly dark in here?
Oh no, what is it that one?
"Memetic Hazard... 1123"
I don't know what 1123 does.
Oh it's not even a keycard. It's just a...
frickin' button!
Ooo..
Ahh, God! Stop spinning me.
I know you're doing that on purpose.
"Don't touch."
Okay.
"...kept in a hermetically sealed container in argon gas atmosphere and not be tested
during storage, temperature..."
"...human skull missing the lower mandible and all it's teeth. Across the "...forehead is modern Khmer script, written in human blood, that translates 'Remember'."
"... they will report anomalous sensory phenomena, including smells... sounds... tactile responses..."
"When subjects touch the surface
they will experience a dissociative fugue state."
"...confusion, disorientation, adoption of a new identity..."
Oooooohhhhh.
Don't touch? I wanna touch it.
Oh, I wanna touch it. Can I save with that?
Oh, I can.
Save.
Got it.
"Nice friggin' site. I got lost four times... trying to... main deck..."
Okay.
So I need your opinion,
Should I touch it?
Should I touch it, guys?
Should I... should I touch it?
There's still people that are saying "run".
Run.
Ahhh.
Nice.
It's the skull. Alright.
Got a gas mask at least.
Maybe I can drop these things 'cause I don't need 'em anymore.
Yep, don't need these.
They're just taking up space.
Should I touch it?
Should I.. Should I touch it? Can I even get in there?
Ahh, no. I can't touch it!
I need a higher clearance.
I wanna touch it so BADLY.
I bet there's a reason to touch it.
I bet if it teaches you a language, that doesn't outright kill you,
like, there's probably a reason...
that you would have to touch that thing.
Right?
I mean it would only make sense.
Maybe.
Damn it.
I'm just gonna keep checkin' to make sure that all these...
Yeah. I think the... I think the lockdown is just not allowing anyone to go through.
Where am I? What the hell is...
Oh God, It turned me around again, I though I changed the whole world on me.
Okay.
Alright, just a hallway.
*exhaaaaaaaale*
Ohhh! I'm at an elevator.
Goddammit. Another elevator.
I don't need elevators. I need...
Ooo..
It's the music!
Ooo, the music's always fun.
Aww, Come On!
Level 1 doesn't do jack-shit!
I'ma... I think I'm about to circle around...
wi
Wha...
I hear you.
SCP-1162. I don't know what that is.
Damn it.
I've got nothing.
Oh, I've got so much nothing.
ma
Uh-oh.
Guard:
"Follow me."
did
Is he creepin'?
*necks snapping*
I saw him moving!
Oh, no.
But I think...
I think if I go down there, I might actually get something important.
That's... It's just another Level 1 isn't it?
Yeah, I don't need a Level 1. But I'll keep it just in case I find the uh...
...the whatcha-ma-who-zit.
[OMG Mark, it's SCP-914]
You know what I'm talking about.
The um... The big machine that transfers things into other machines and I...
I can't remember.
[Wow, Mark. Just.. wow.]
But I gotta go down there!
Alright..
Hey, buddy.
Hey buddy, hey buddy, hey buddy, hey.
I don't know what I picked up.
Oh..
Heyyyy....
Aaalright.
*breathy*
harner...
HEY!
Oh, Fuck me.
*deep exhale*
Fuck.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gotta get around it, and up, and close that door.
Just gotta get up, around, and close it... I really hope the thing where it doesn't swing my vision around.
Doesn't happen when I'm near that thing, 'cause that is instant death.
That's 100% death.
Okay, what did I even get?
I got a clipboard? Goddammit. It's a clipboard that can hold all the papers.
But I don't need the papers.
Ay..
*neck snaps*
AH!
Fffff
FffffUUUUUUUUUUUU
FffffUUUUUUUUUUUUuuu
FffffUUUUUUUUUUUUuuuck...
Memory access violation. Great!
Can't even load.
*sharp exhale*
Let me try to get back in here. Let me try to get back in.
*exhale*
I forgot how much this game can spook ya...
Game's spooky.
Game's real spooky...
Alright. Let's see if it's gonna load...
Oh boy.
Wheeeeeeeeew..
Alright.
Hooooo...
Woooo-oo!
Okay. Alright.
Huuuh...
Okay. Looks like it loaded but I'm back where I didn't wanna be.
So I'm gonna real quick... I'm gonna...
I'm gonna... Uh...
I'm gonna try to read some chat real quick.
'Cause I've been a little bit away from that.
Oh boy.
My whole... My whole, uh... My whole Chrome crashed.
Makes me think that maybe the RAM in my computer...
This is the same computer that I've using since umm...
...since I first came to LA.
I think it might be the time to upgrade my computer pretty soon, but uh...
Until then, I'm desperately not gonna hold onto that.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna desperately cling onto this computer as long as I can.
If I can, I'm gonna be...
...very happy about that but...
We're gonna get back into it. Let me just uh...
Get back here.
Fuuuuuck...
...that's no good...
Huh... *Un-kh!*
Alright.
Oh boy. Okay.
So I'ma try this again.
Here we go. Here we go and...
Blahbadie blubadie blip-blap.
Where am I? Where are you?
There we go.
Okay.
Alright.
"If I'm correct..." Max Lavine says.
"The Larry seed would make SCP-106 active as all fuuuuck!"
Let's see.
Uh... Jessica Katnick say,
"Ahh, Markimoo died. Where's Chica?"
Chica's not in here right now.
Chica's laying in her bed.
Ah man.
TheSpy said, "It's so nice to see you get back into SCP. It's the reason I sub-ed originally back when you had seven-thousand subscribers."
Thank you so much.
Uh... Grace Caroline says,
"Mark, I wanted to tell you that your determination inspired me to apply for uni[versity]..
..Got in. I'll be starting my BA Psyc. next year. Love you lots."
Well, good luck you...
...in university.
So thank you, so much.
Alright.
Giovanna Malone says,
"I'm home, sick. But I'm glad I'm home to watch you. You always makes me feel better and I'm so lucky to have you in my life..
..I gave you a letter of Packsys this year. If you find it, please let me know."
I've got a few boxes of Packsys stuff over in my living-room right now.
I mean to do a video of that very soon and I'll try to get back to that as soon as I can, but...
It takes a lot to get to, so...
Oh, DarkShadow says, "SCP Larry's coming for you! Seriously, though, great to see you back in SCP."
Well, thank you so much, I'm glad to be here too.
Um... Some- a Russian name I can't pronounce says: "Hi! I'm from Russia. I have a question:..
..Are you the Trace Legacy character prototype? And who is Flora prototype then?"
I have no idea. I have no idea wha- Oh... Are you talking about my brother's comic?
'Cause he has characters named Trace and Flora.
I'm assuming you mean the inspiration for those characters? No, I'm not.
I don't think I'm any inspiration for that, and I honestly don't know, you'd have to ask my brother on that one about his comic.
My brother writes the comic TwoKinds, for those of you who have read that or heard of it before.
It's a pretty popular webcomic, he's been doing it for like thirteen, fourteen years now, so...
Pretty proud of my brother and what he's done, so if you're ever into webcomics or stuff like that, check those out.
Twokinds.net. "Two" spelled out not like the number...
Well, I mean, it is the number, but it is the number "two" spelled out. "T-W-O-kinds.net", I think it is.
Anyway. So, back into this.
We gotta get back. So if I recaaall, I'm gonna go over here...
That's nothing...
This is a hallway, and then, at the end of this is an elevator, and then, I'm back where I need to be.
Yeah, okay.
So...
Oh, shit! Go- Stop doing that! It's doing that on purpose!
It's not me!
Ugh!
Wish I knew why...
Uh-oh...
*SCP-173 moving*
*metallic noises*
Kay...
Distant Guard:
"I think the shortest way out is through the South-East wing. Follow me."
Scientist:
"Did you hear that?"
Okay, they're dead...
I don't need to go back down there.
I don't need to know about 173, but I guess I will get a clipboard eventually. Don't need that...
Gotta get the batteries...
Okay, I'm gonna go down there, I'm gonna get the batteries... It's gonna be super cool, and chill, and awesome
and where the hell is he? I don't know which side he's on...
Ah, okay, I see him.
Ah, no you don't!
Yeah, okay. Alright, then. Don't even fuckin' try... me bruh.
Alright. I'm out, I'm out, I'm outtie, I'm outtie, I Don't Have A Lot Of Time! I'm Outtie!
Oh, I'm Outtie!
Okay, this time, don't fuckin' open that goddamn door!
Where's the goddamn door thing?
Okay!
Okay.
Guuch!
Ah! It worked!
Okay. These are - uhhhh-ookay?
I don't know what that is.
"Ear-like..." Oh, that's the ear thing.
I know about the ear thing, the ear thing's weird.
Okay, I'm gonna close this bad boy!
Alright. Where am I? I have no idea.
Oh! ... How the fuck ... did you get there?
Hey!
Ffffucking goddammit!
Oh God, oh God, oh God!
Oh God, oh God, oh God! Okay.
Alright. I need to get back in there. There's a Level 2 key-card in there.
Fuck.
Fuuuuck!
Faaaah-ck!
Fuck!
I have to draw him out, somehow.
Okay... I.. he's prolly' still there... Yep, he's still there!
Oh, I can't get around him! I have to get him around here.
Okay. Blink!
Okay, alright. Don't fuck on me-
(LOUD)
AHHH! FFFF-
IT DID THE THING!
*exhale*
Did the thing.
It did the thing...
..where you look...
*Mark exhaling all his frustration x2*
It's okay... Everybody, you're alright. You're alright, you're alright. It's okay.
I can't save at any time, I want you guys to know this.
In this particular game mode, they've updated it, so there's a difficulty where you can only save at computer terminals.
And you know what? I'm just gonna forget... I'ma just fuckin' forget about getting the goddamn clipboard, cause...
honestly, who needs a clipboard?
The clipboard is not important. The clipboard is just NOT... in the least bit... important.
Ah, he's not here, right now!
He's not here right now, Mrs. Torrance!
Okay.
So, we're good there...Lock that up- wait!
Ah! Level 2 key-card! Now we don't need the Level 1 anymore, but I'm gonna just hold onto it just in case.
But I've also got this: the Navigator!
And this, has batteries in it,
So, this shows me where I've been and where I need to go.
Oh shit, another air-lock...
Fuck!
Don't fuck with me...
Fff- Don't, Stop, Do That!
Stop! Stop do that!
Stop do that!
Godfucking- I hate that!
I hate that so goddamn much!
*key-card decline* Dammit, higher clearance!
*key-card decline* Dammit, Level 2 is still not enough!
Pffff. Oh no...
Can I run throuh this? ... Okay, I can.
That's a Tesla gate, that's one of the ways to stop Radical Larry.
If Radical Larry goes through that, when it's active, it'll zap him dead!
Pfffff... I need a console to save.
Fuck!
Okay, so I haven't gone... South goes nowhere, apparently.
Let's just see where that goes...
Okay, the South goes nowhere.
And I have not gone this way.
Ah, is- *excited gasp*
... It's 914!
Ooh shiiiiiit, dude!
Okay, please tell me this is enough...
Yesss!
Okay, so I'm in here... Oh fuck. Oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck.
Fuck fuck fuck fuck fuck.
Key-card, lock me in...
Okay!
Shit. Okay. I need to remember-
Dr. L: - "I don't know why I'm bothering. I'm the only one alive anymore, I think."
"Or maybe just... sane? Or am I even that much at this point? I feel like I have to leave something behind,"
"some shard of myself. I've seen the others, I know I'll most likely not even leave the day... *a body."
"So, maybe that's what this is."
"Shivering myself off... *Slivering myself off, leaving breadcrumbs of my brain, scattered and tattered."
"I keep learning things in the dark, it's almost worse than what's in the light. I taste metal."
What the fuck does that mean?!
Yeah... So, anyway, this machine is the refinery.
It, um...
It basically will refine pretty much aything you have in various, different ways.
"As a reminder, no organic matter is to be entered in to SCP-914 at any time."
"Please follow standard review procedures in regards to input booth checklists."
"We do not with a repeat of the spider/steel incident of last week."
Okay..
So, if you guys remember...
..if you guys remember, there is some way to get the key-card to get better.
Now, I can't remember the exact way to do that, but there is a way to do it.
And I need you guys to tell me exactly how to do that.
So, if you guys... I'm- I'm looking at chat, right now, uh, and I hope you guys have an answer for me.
So, I'm just gonna read some things...
Uh, SofaKing says, "What is this? 2014? All jokes aside though, it's great to see you playing an old fan-favorite...
..Never forget, Mark, that you've got people everywhere who will support you, even people in the military like me..
..I look forward to seeing you playing this game again in another three years."
Awww, that's very optimistic about my channel, but thank you so much!
In three years... It'll be the year 2020, so... Honestly, who knows what's gonna happen in 2020...
Uh, Nova says, "Hey, Mark, my name is Novas, and I'm a small YouTuber trying to reach 100 subs...
..I wonder if you'd be able to help me reach my goal."
Well, I just said your name, so, hopefully, that helps.
BlueSpartanGaming says, "I would love it if you played Inspire, a Markiplier fan game, on your channel..
..It's a game I put a lot of effort into, and I'm starting working on a sequel. It would be an achievement for me to see you play it."
I do wanna play more Markiplier fan games. And, in fact, I like the format of doing, like, a live-stream of this, uh, for that.
So, I hope that, some day, I'll be able to do that in terms of, just like, doing a live-stream with you guys and then uh...
You know, just- just being able to do that, and see you guys, and talk to you guys about it...
You know.
I-It could be- It could be just a lot of fun, and I really do appreciate that.
Um...
Matthias Professor Barbaddo... *Barbado says, "Hi, Mark, I'm a Brazilian history teacher and pod-caster..
..I follow you for about four years now, and I love your work...
..You help me pass through some bad moments in my life. Thank you."
Uh... Anthony Earl says, "Love you, Markiboo!" Molly says... uh... Oh, wait, no I actually read that one, I believe.
Molly... I-It's another personal story. This is, uh, just thanking me for helping her through a very tough time in her life
and I hope you're doing okay, Molly. I really hope you are.
Uh... Jessica Steiner says, "You're an amazing person, Mark. You have a huge heart and a beautiful soul..
..Thank you for everything you're doing for us."
Uh, yes, I will be playing Outlast 2.
Okay. "Try the Level 1 key-card on the 1:1 setting first."
JJ Kim says, "Wow! My future husband is really cold. No, but thanks for the constant mood lifting with your videos."
Midi the Wolf says, "Third and last time I'm posting this, but coming from crippling bedridden for four years, I can say  that you save lives..
..You saved mine, anyways. Thanks."
I really do appreciate that. I'm glad that I was able to help you through those times.
Like, I can't imagine what it's like to be bedridden for four years.
Let alone some people that are watching that have been bedridden for their entire life, and thats-
that's a horrible thing to go through, and I'm glad that my videos can help some way.
So. Anymay, I've got the advice of going, uh... uh... going for 1:1, and then...
Oh, Shelmet said, "Mark, get the better card, ya bitch, and go touch dat skull!..
..DOOOO IIIIIIIT!"
So, I'ma go do that, but after I read this.
So, someone said to take the level 1 and put it on 1:1 and fine. Unfortunately, I can't save, right now.
Whooooaa, hey buddy...
Okay... Don't- Don't dick with me.
I think it's Level 1 and then 1:1. That's what they said.
Level 1... 1:1... I-I remember, it used to be fine, but they said 1:1, so I'm gonna trust them...
And they- They definitely improved the sound effects on this one.
That is a playing card. That doesn't help me in any capacity. That didn't work at all!
Hang on, let me try this again. 1:1...
Ker-Chunkles!
(reading chat)
"Stick the card up your butt!" Do you really think that's a good option for me?
Sticking the card up my butt. What is that gonna do for me?
Okay, so it made it back into a Level 1 keycard. So, let me try Fine...
I'ma try Fine, let's see... I-I remember that used to work.
Bloop!
Hmmmm...
Who the frick was that?
Alright... Ah, nope, that just turned it into a MasterCard, which didn't do me any good.
Okay, let's see if I can get it back into working order.
Shhhhhhoop!
Let's see... "Level 2 card on fine", and then, someone said "Level 2 card on Very Fine", and I'm like.... "Eeeeeh..."
I don't want to risk my card like that, cause I can't saaaave.
Oooo...
Well, I got another Level 2 key-card, so... I guess, alright, you know what? I'm gonna put a Level 2 on...
I'm gonna put a Level 2 on... Very Fine!
Choop!
Let's see if this works. I don't know...
..It's a MasterCard again. Okay, so I'm gonna try this:
What if I put the MasterCard in here, and then Very Fine again, and then...
Shoop!
[What beautiful eyes you have, Mark]
... It's a Level 2 again! Okay, so...
So!
I've got a Level 2...
So the only thing- whoa, okay.
The only thing I haven't tried is Level 2 on Fine.
Shhhoop!
I mean, they may have removed this ability for this to, uh... be improved like this.
I'm gonna put the Navigator in there soon, because I do want the Deluxe- woooo!
THAT is a Level 3 card!
I got it! Okay! I'll take a Level 3!
I'm gonna put the Navigator in there and put that on Fine.
I think Extra Fine will just break it.
Camera is blurry?
What do you mean, camera is blurry?
What does that even mean?
Okay, I think this is the super Navigator now.
Ah, yes.
The super Navigator with all the maps already done.
Okay.
"Try Rough"? I'm not gonna do that!
"Put the S-NAV on very fine"?
I thought the S-NAV on just Fine was good enough.
You guys are leading me astray here.
I don't about that but I've got a Level 3 card...
and I think that's gonna be good enough.
Alright, you know what? I'ma go- I'ma touch the skull. I'ma gonna touch the skull! I'ma just- I'ma go touch the skull!
'Cause then I can save and come back
because I got a Level 3 and a better Navigator and..
I think that's gonna be good enough so I'ma go touch the skull
and probably die a horrible death.
*breathy*
haner...
Good thing I left all these doors open
that's definitely gonna help me in the long run.
*breathy*
haner...
*weird noise*
The fuck was that?
Whoa, what is this?
What is this?
What IS this?
what is- HEY! Stop that!
Stop that..
Well there's a playing card,
but I don't need that.
It's another Navigator but
I guess..
Ahh Fucking STOP THAT!
OHH! Radical Larry.
Hi Hi Hi
Okay, alright, that's bad.
I don't know how to stop you, just yet.
I needed to go touch the skull and you're chasing me now.
Aw fuck.
Ahh, shitty-tits.
Oh boy.
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy, oh boy. Okay.
Yup, that's that's that's that.
Hey!
OOH NO!
Oh No!
Oh No, oh no, oh no, oh no, Oh No, OH NO!
Oh Fuck, open.
And close.
Ok. Alright.
This bad.
Oh, where the fuck am I?!
I didn't mean to come in here.
This is not where I meant to go.
Fuck.
Shit.
Ahhh dicks.
Ahhh poopy
*PBBBBBBBHT!*
*PBBHT*
Alright.
Aw fuck.
I'm just waiting for that- yeah, hi.
Yeah, a Decayed March. Yeah, that's no good.
Kay, where are you?
Oh Fuck you're right in front of me- ok he's faster than, he's faster than he used to be
by a good margin.
Ok blink-blonk-
Don't be... goddammi- Don't... Oh, goddammit!
You fuckin' asshole!
Fuck you!
Fuck You!
Fuuuuck You!
FFUUUUHK YOU!
Fuck you.
..fuck you..
Just- Fuck you.
Yeh yeh-
Ring Around The Fuckin' Rosie.
Bitch.
Haner yourself into Fuckin' Death!
Ya' piece a shit.
I gotta get to the goddamn save-point.
'Cause fuck!
Wait- what was the skull- is the skull in here?
I forget.
Ah shit.
SHIT- what is tha
I dunno where that goes out- I'll be right back.
For that.
I- I just need a goddamn-
fuck, stop spinning me...
I just need a goddamn thing-
SCP-500
SCP-1499
OooOOOohH- save.
Yes. Save.
boop.
Okay-
*sighs* Ah, fuck.
Alright...
Okay- we're doin' okay...
We're doin' alright...
As long as we can get through this...
*mouth stuff... noises*
*exhales*
Kay- What are these things...
I don't know what this is
higher clearance...
Good enough clearance...
What are you?
Well that looks...
That looks bad.
That looks like something I shouldn't take.
THAT looks like something I definitely shouldn't take.
I'm gonna read up on it first.
Okay-
"Gas mask, seal.. anomalous effects, one second, subject vanishes from view, is no longer detectable, subject reports no feeling of motion, two-way radios..."
whaaaaaat?
Whaaaat?
Whooooaaa...
Weeeird.
The ffuck is thaaa...
I'ma put it on.
let's- let's-
Let's put it on!
Okaaayy...
ooohhhhhhhh...
Hi...
Ooohhhh,
Hi.
Hidey, hidey, hidey,
ho.
Oh no..
Oh no....
Oh, where am I?
OH!
Dafuq is that?!
What are you humpin' your way down the road?
♫Humping my way downtown♫
♫Walking fast...
Okay-
that's weird.
I guess I'll go towards 'em.
What they gonna do,
KILL me?
Well there's a lot of 'em.
Haner.
Haner haner haner.
HANER!
Haaaner
Haner...
Hello...
Hi...
Hello!
Hi.
Hello?
Where ya goin'?
What ya doing?
Hello...
Ya runnin' from me?
What are you?
Eeeh...
I don't like this.
Oo..
Eeh.
Hello!
UUUuuuhhh...
Oh, your weird.
AYE!
Oow!
OW!
HEY!
HEY HEY HEY!
Oooohh God.
They're all after me!
OOOoohh God!
I'm taking it off!
Ow.
I seem to be bleeing profusely.
Gonna put on this first aid kit because holy shit.
Ooof...
"Your wounds are way too severe to staunch the bleeding comple-"
OH!
I'm gonna die.
Oh.
Is that what your saying...?
I'm gonna- I'ma gonna-
DIE.
I'm just limping along!
EH!
EAH!
AH!
Maybe it was a bad idea...
Well- better finish it off, I guess.
Oh, where am I NOW?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's just an empty spot.
What the fuck?
WELL! I'ma die.
That's the long and the short of that one.
I am a dead man who-
"The corner of your eye-"
What the fuck are you talking about...?
StOOOp.
StOOOp the corner of my eye...
Oh no...
Oh no.
OH NO.
I'm real short now, oh no.
OH-
NO!
OH DOE!
I'm losing a lot of blood!
OH DOE.
I'm gonna die now, OH DOE.
OH NO.
OH *GHH*NO.
Oh no, I'm gonna die.
Oh DOE!
Oh DOE.
Oo, ow. It hurts a lot.
Just marching along oh no.
Let's see what's up here anyway since I'm gonna die no matter what.
SPRINT!
RUN!
Ruuun!
I can't even...
I can't walk up stairs...
Well, SHIT.
Oh Doe.
Oh Fuck.
Uh-oh...
Looks like I- OH, is that MY blood?
Oh it's hard to look at...
Welp I'm just gonna stay here and embrace the sweet..
Sweet, sweet, sweet, embrace o' death.
Yeah, I'm dyin'...
yeah I'm dyin'..
So um uh, "You're feeling faint from the amount of blood you lost."
Is that a Radical Larry behind me, or is that a SCP-
*loud static*
*gasp*
Fffffffffff-...
Fuck Youuu.
Why would you do that?
Why would you do that?!
*quietly*
Why would you do that..
Ooh- I can't see shit here.
Larry...
Billy.
Either one of you, just end my misery please.
I'm just gonna load the game.
I'ma load the game because...
That was takin' way too long.
Okay.
So now that I'm not dying, I'm gonna go back here.
I'm gonna investigate.
Oh!
Look, my blood is still there, who would've thought?
'Kay, I'm gonna investigate what's up here...
Oooo, this looks important...
This looks vury import-
whoa, stop that!
Stop it!
Okay, this looks like the power control room that the computer SCP wanted me to turn on.
But it is slightly dead.
*spooky noise enables spooked Mark*
*realizes that the SCP-049 is coming*
Wait, you're c- Wait, I'm in there!
Wait! No! Wait!
Wait wait wait!
Wait!
Wait Wait Wait!
*key-card decline*
Oh fuck! Wait!
Wait, wait, wait!
Hi!
Hi.
Uh, urgh, uh, no! I'd rather not!
No! (x25)
No! (x34)
Lock it! (x4)
No no no no- ah, shit! Ah, fuck!
SCP-049:
"I sense the disease in you."
Uh, too bad, I don't want the disease in me!
I like the disease!
Uh-oh. (x12)
Ooooo....
*sighs*
Well...
that didn't go good for me...
Was it good for you?
Shit.
Okay...
We are in trouble.
So, I need to get by that doctor to be able to go up in that control room;
because, I bet that's a control room to release the lock-down.
*inhales*
*exhales*
Stop doing that achievement! "The Corner Of Your Eye" Achievement. I don't like that achievement.
Ah, don't like that achievement.
SCP-049:
*inaudible*
So, he's there...
How do I get by him?
Do I gotta go the long way around?
Looks like I gotta.
Pffff...Alrighty then... Let's do that one.
Fuuudge...
Wo- wha! ...
Who's got big thumping footsteps?
Oh boy...
Stop that!
Okay, so where am I going?
I need to go all the way back around to the other side.
I need to get back to that machine again, because I'm pretty sure there's gotta be a way that I can make a higher level of this card.
I just have to find it.
Fuck.
Okay.
I need to stop being a little baby about this.
Pfff.
So I know those go nowhere...
because according to this map, they just go nowhere-
Oooo! It's the skull!
Oh, I'm gonna touch it!
Hang on, I gotta save first.
Boop!
Save!
Put this away.
I'ma touch it! I'ma touch that son o' bitch!
Oooo, I'ma touch it!
Urgh, I'ma touch it!
UHHH Yeah, I'ma touch THAAT!
Boop!
Ah, shit!
Uuuuh... yup.
Boop!
Oooh.
Uh-oh!
Uh-oh.
Oh!
[This is a poster inciting German people to revolt against Hitler and denouncing all the deaths and misery brought by the war and the Wehrmacht. The handwritten notes say: "Sorry, Helen. I wish I could have been here."]
Dafuqqin' fuuck!
German Soldier:
"Komm!"
Oh... Hi.
German Soldier 2:
"Jetzt, komm schon!"
Oh my God, are you a Nazi?
Ooooooh... kay.
Oookay...
Alrighty then...
Oh...
Holy shit!
What the fuuuuck?
Oh God! This isn't the same!
Oh no!
Oh Nooo!
Oh nOOo!
Oh, oh noo!
Oh no, where am I?
Oh, where am I? Oh, where am I?
Oh, hi! Hello! Okay.
Well, I'm back to the death-walk!
I'm gonna die, Oh Doe!
OH Doe!
Oh doe!
Death is claiming me!
Oh doe..
German Soldier 1:
"... sieht aus wie einer." *giggles*
German Soldier 2:
"Jetzt weiß ich es."
I can't see anything!
German Soldier 1:
"Du bist Deutscher...und Jude."
(bang!)
Oh, aye! Okay, alright then...
Ah...
I'm dead.
And I'm not dead...?
*whispering*
Whaaat?
What the fuck?!
That's so weird.
Wha- that was so weird!
I can only imagine,
that was like a skull...
... from someone from the concentration camps of World War II during the Holocaust.
That's what that seemed like that was...
What the fuck?!
The fuck!
Was that what that was?
I don't know...
I don't d'oh...
Oh my God... I'ma save, cause it seems like I'm okay!
*whispering*
What the fuck?!
That's so messed up!
Oh, man. Okay...
Carrying on...
*whispering*
Fuuuck!...
Carrying on.
(reads the chat)
"Touch it again?" "Touch it again?!"
Alright, fine, I'ma touch it again; but if it's the same thing, I'ma be very pissed.
Alright, I'm gonna touch it.
I can't carry more items.
Yeah, it won't let me touch it again. I'm not gonna-
I'm not gonna touch it again, I think I learned my lesson the first time around.
'Cause holy shit!
*deep exhale*
Okay. So I'ma make my way back all the way around to the machine again.
And I'ma try to get a higher level card, because that's what I need right now.
I could go in there, I don't know if there's gonna be any benefit to goin' there.
Other than the music that makes me wanna write it and kill myself.
Fucking stop that!
(door automatically opens)
Fuck!
Uh-oh...
Uh-oh!
Uh-oh... I- I can't- it's doin' it automatically!
Boobiddy boop boop!
Did you guys know about this one?
Can't help it, gotta write.
Oh boy, here we go!
Ow!
D-9341:
*gasps* "I have to...I have to finish it..."
I have to-
D-9341:
"Do you really wanna do it?" *grunts*
*struggling sounds*
D-9341:
"I don't... think... I can do this..."
*painful groans*
D-9341:
"I... have... no... ch- choice!"
"Balloons... (psychotic laughter) This makes... no sense..."
Yep. Yep, you're... yep.
Yeah, it's bad. Yeah, it's bad.
Yeah, it's bad. Yeah, it's pretty bad, it's bad. Yeah, it's bad. It's bad.
D-9341:
(distorted voice) "This... is... impossible!"
Uh oh...
D-9341:
(psychotic laughter)
"It... it can't be completed!"
Uh oh... I think I died.
Clump!
Well, yeah. That's a lesson about that one.
Eh...
I only wrote three lines... That's all I did, that's all I did.
Oh, "Memor-" no!
Noooo, Memory Access Violation, nooooo!
Dooooe!
Doooe!
Alright, I'm goin' back in. I'm goin' back in.
Yeah, why did I do that? A lot of people are like: "Why did you do that?"
I was like, "Eh, just to show you guys what was going on."
To show you guys another funky way to die!
Oh, also, someone said...
Someone said to get the mask that took you to the other world
and bring it to the machine, and that's actually a really good idea.
I'ma go back and try to get that.
'Cause I think that's just before the P- *burp* Excuse me! - the Plague Doctor's there.
So if I can get that from before the Plague Doctor actually is there, then hopefully I, will be able to grab that and take it with me all the way around.
I'll just have to backtrack a little bit. But it's important, because if that is something that can be put in the machine
and turned into something really cool, then I wanna know what that is.
So I'ma find that. And I'ma do that.
As crazy as it is down there in Crazo-Land...
Bloink! Okay! So I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna find that.
Hope nothing kills me on the way...
Haner.
Haner-haner...
Haner, haner, haner...
Yeee...
Okay...
So I- I obviously can't take the skull with me, so I can't put that in the machine at all.
But, I can definitely take that mask, which I thiiink was juuust over the rainbow here...
Just around the river-bend...
Somewhere here. God, it couldn't have been that far away!
Maybe the Plague Doctor is gone by now, and then I can go back the other way and hopefully,
...that's gonna be a little bit easy f-
(walks on Larry's stuff)
Fuck, I forgot about that!
Ergh!
Okay... Everything's fine, everything's fine...
Good, good, good, good, good.
So far so good.
Alright.
Huuh, I always get so anxious when I walk through these halls, cause I'm like, at any moment, you could have
either Larry or Billy pop-up out of nowhere and just fuck your day up!
Okay, I think it was here, was it here?  Yeah, it was here, okay.
What's that? What is that?
"Emily Ross"? Who the hell is Emily Ross?
So it's a Level 2 keycard, but...
Well, I mean, I don't need it, I guess...
Save.
Okay...
'Kay...
Maybe Emily Ross could open this one?
No, I can't even do it, it's just an ID-card.
Okay. I'm gona take this with me.
I'm not gonna put it on, but I'm gonna take it with me.
And I'ma go- It sounds like there's a Plague Doctor right here!
No?
Alright...
Okay...
Alright then.
Okay. He seems to be gone, okay...
I believe that...
Ooo, fuckin' fuckin'- goddammit! Noooo!
*loud static*
Oh, fuck, this bad!
Well, shitty tits!
Off...
eh- I can't even turn off the heavy containment zone, but at least, I got that off!
Alright, Larry, where you at? Oh, Larry... Oh, Larry... Oh, Larry! Oh, Larry!
Oh, you're not just walking through shit, this time!
How polite of you. And weird, and out of character, and I don't like that...
Yee...
Yee... Okay, alright. Go go go go go...
Go go go, no time to waste.
We gotta go, we gotta go, we gotta go, we gotta go.
We gotta go!
Okay.
Is this it? No this was not it. This is 100% not it, but what is this?
Oh yeah, that's that weird room that led you nowhere. And goddammit, I'm wasting time here.
Okay, I think he stopped... That was- that was Larry stopping?
Was that stoppin'? I think he stopped. I'm not 100% sure.
Okay..
It wasn't there... Fuckin' stop that!
Where was it? Where was it?
Oh, this was it! This was it! This was it! This was it!
Okay!
So!
Alright. So we got a lotta shit.
But I need your opinion on this one. I need to know: this is my inventory right now. I have a gas-mask that is an SCP...
... I have a playing card, I have an "Emily Ross" badge, I have a Navigator, I have a normal gas-mask, and a cup.
And two keycards.
So, I need to turn these things into better versions of these things. So, in the comments,
write what I need to do. Make sense?
I'll also read some of the comments that have been coming behind since I last read them.
So, uh, JJ Kem... Oh, I already read that one. Um...
So, Krojak says, "I saw your video 'Pursuit of Happiness' two years ago, and it inspired me like you could never understand..
..Now, I'm at 123,000 subscribers and I'm living my dream, this is all thanks to you."
Well, thank you so much, and I'm glad that you are able to pursue your dream.
Brownates- Brownite Psycho said, "Hey, Mark. I'm glad you're playing the game that got me watching your channel in the first place..
..Thank you so much for helping through my depression..
..thank you for taking a photo of my fan-game at Pax, it meant a lot to me that you cared enough to do that..
..As long as you're here, we'll be here too."
And yes, I do wanna play more of those fan games. I do intend to-
I wanna do a livestream where I just play a whole bunch of 'em.
Chris Berlon said, "OMG, I'd never thought I'd see more SCP Containment Breach! Mark, I love you!"
Well, thank you so much!
And then, uh, Nicholas Louis says, "Can you please say hi to me, and my friend Sarah Garlic?..
..Also, where have you decided to go on tour?"
We haven't decided the exact cities yet, but we're thinking...
We're thinking vaguely in...
Uh... Nah I can't even say. I really can't say, because I'd just be spoiling it and, uh...
and ruining possibilities of doing these things, so... I wanna do... I wanna be...
I wanna tell you guys everything, and we will tell you everything very soon, but...
Just a little bit longer. We'll know exactly when.
Okay. Gas mask + fine = unlimited stamina, okay. I believe you there...
See, gas mask on fine. So, I'm gonna do that first. I'm gonna ju- put the gas mask on fine...
There's other things to do besides that, though. I know that for sure.
I know the SCP thing can probably be done as well.
Shonk!
Okay.
(reading chat)
"The weird gas mask on ultra-fine" or.. er.. Very-Fine...
You said "ultra-fine", so I-I think you maybe not know.
"You can breathe easier."
Okay, it's not unlimited stamina- oh, it is unlimited stamina, that's right! That's weird... Yeah, good stuff!
Good stuUUuuuff! Stop skittering you.. Bastard!
Okay, "Battery on Very-Fine"?
Wait, hang on... Maybe I'm not reading this right, hang on...
"Level 3 to extra-fine"...
"Put the ID on very fine." Okay, I'll put the ID on very fine, because that's not loosing anything, but I'm gonna try that.
Alright. ID... on Very-Fine.
(spinning)
Whoa! That was a big twist. Okay...
Okay. What do we got here?
Ooooo...
What'd it do?
It didn't do anything!
What?!
Why would it... Why didn't it do anything to it?
There's a QR code on this. I don't know what that would lead to.
Wait, hang on. Let me scan this QR code on my phone here... Cuz I'm curious...
[It's gonna] steal all my stuff, but I'm gonna scan this QR code, because that is...
...it's peculiar.
*chuckle* Uuuh, yeah. just... literally, that's just the data of the card.
But it does show a code here. There is a code...
Why is there a code here?
It's a code. There's a code here that says: 55.678741-4.065784
So, are those coordinates? Once again, I'm gonna read this.
The code says it's 55.678741-4.065784
So, whatever that code means, it might be latitude-longitude coordinates or it might be a code to something else.
Or maybe you're supposed to substract it, cause  it might be a substraction symbol instead of just a dash, but... That's something.
I don't know what that is, but that is something. So, maybe you guys can figure that out. Okay.
Okay. Level 2 key-card on Fine for Level 3... What do I do for the Level 3 key-card?
You guys are saying Level 3 key-card on Very fine, so I'm gonna trust you on that one.
I didn't save, so if this screws it up, then... it's your fault. Mmm, that little thing is skittering in here with me.
Aaaaah, it's a MasterCard. Ah, shit! Alrighty then, we're gonna try this this way... Put this back...
Blap!
"Level 3 on Fine?"
Eh, you were sayin' Very-Fine. I'm gettin' mixed messages here.
(reads chat)
"SUPA-Fine!"
I don't think supa-fine is it.
Oh, goddammit it downgraded it to Level 2.
So, Level 2 on Fine created the...
Level 2 on Fine created the Level 3, right?
That's what it did.
I believe, anyway.
So, what happens if you put Level 3 on Fine?
That would probably, maybe get it up to Level 4.
I don't know.
Oh, it's a MasterCard again, goddammit.
Oooh boy, this is gonna be a bitch, isn't it?
Pbbbbbbbbht...
No, Level 2 again, gaddammit.
Level 2 on Very-Fine?
Is that it?
(reading chat)
Level 3 on 1:1.
That might be it, that might be it.
That might be it. Okay, someone said playing-card on Very-Fine.
Playing-card on Very-Fine.
And then Level 3 on 1:1.
That would make more sense.
Oh shit, Oh Shit! Why here?
Why now?!
Oh no.
Oh Doe!
Oh no, I gotta go.
I gotta go.
I gotta leave.
Fuck, but I gotta get what was in there.
Shit, okay. I'ma try dodge 'em.
Fuck Yooou!
Ah, shit.
Got- grab it, grab it.
Level 2, Fuck!
Not what I WANTED!
I gotta put on the gas-mask, okay.
Hup! Let's go!
Shoop. Okay, we're gonna shoop outta here.
Shoobiddy, shoobiddy, shoobiddy, shoobiddy.
I'm so fast.
Shoobiddy, shoobiddy, shoobiddy, shoobiddy, shoobiddy, shoobiddy, shoobiddy.
Shoobiddy, shoobiddy, shoobiddy, shoobiddy.
Okay.
Is he still following me?
Okay. So, I have two Level 2's and a MasterCard now.
Not exactly what I wanted.
But it's what I got!
I need to get back there.
I gotta get back there.
There's a way to get a Level 4 card; but, I just haven't been able to do it.
Alright..
Is he still there?
Uh! He is there.
Okay, I just gotta get far enough away.
Man, I am soo fast!
I am ludicrously fast!
Okay...
Save.
'Kay, sounds like he's gone. Okay, I'm gonna go back there.
Good, good, good, good, good.
Okay...
I am SOOO Fast!
Fuck, dude.
okay.
So I'm gonna get this.
Alright.
This off...
Okay, I'm gonna do a little goof.
I'm gonna put the SCP gas-mask in there.
And I'ma put that on Very-Fine, see what happens.
If that works, great!
If it doesn't, fuck!
AYE, OH, WHOA, Whoa, Whoa!
What The Fucking Fuck You!
Okaay!
Ow!
Ow.
I'm dead. Okay.
Well, fuck me then.
Okay.
(reading screen)
Uniden- Unidentified male and a deceased Class D subject were discovered in -blank- by Nine-Tailed Fox.
The man was described as highly agitated and seemed to only speak Russian.
(reading screen)
He's been taken into a temporary holding area at -redacted- while waiting for a translator to arrive.
Whaaat?
Weeeird..
WeeEEEird.
Weeeird, okay.
Weird.
Whoa. That was super weird.
I have no idea what was goin' on with that.
That was sooo weird.
That was so weird!
[Hey Mark, was it weird by chance?]
You guy knew that that was gonna happen, didn't ya?
You guys knew.
Some of you anyway.
A lot of you might have been j- oh yeah, a lot of you are just as surprised as I am.
But some of you guys knew!
You knew what was gonna happen.
I see your game.
Okay, I gotcha. Okay.
I see.. Okay!
So let's NOT do that again.
And let's try to get this.
Into a...
Some sort of a Level 3.
I gotta get a Level 3 here.
'Cause I need at least the Level 3 again.
To try to do the 1:1.
'Cause if i can do that then I'm
better off.
Ah, that's a Level 2..
God, I've got so many Level 2's now.
Lemme try Level 2 on 1:1.
Pbbbbbht..
That's a playing-card again.
Lemme try playing-card on 1:1.
Med-kit on Very-Fine.
I am gonna do that. I know that's gonna be -
either bad or very good; I can't remember which is which.
Aww Jesus, it just made a Level 1 key-card.
Fuck.
Level 1 on Very-Fine did nothing, right?
*quietly*
What'd that do..
'Cause I can't progress anywhere unless I get these.
But I- I did open up the containment area.
So I can go to the containment areas.
But I do need a higher level c-
whoa.. what is that?
Oh my Goood.
It's the Omni-card.
It's the fuckin' Omni-card.
The Omni-card can unlock ANYTHING.
OOH SHIT, Duuude!
OOH Fuuuck!
Ahh Fuck, dude.
Okay.
So, that's good.
I'm gonna...
I'm- I'm gonna..
I- I can't remem- di- wait.
Is this a trap?
Is this a trap?!
First-aid on Very-Fine.
Is that a trap? I think that kills me, doesn't it?
That kills me, doesn't it?
That kills me! Doesn't it?
That kills me, doooesn't it?
That kills me. I know this is good, but...
That kills me, doesn't it?
No, that kill- that kills me! I know that's a trap!
That's a trap. You guys are trickin' me, that kills me.
Yeah, you guys are trickin' me. You-
Oh...
You guys are trickin' me.
You guys are trickin' me, yeah.
Yeah, okay. Alright.
So, I got the Ultimate Navigator,
and the gas-mask that allows me to run indefinitely.
So, I just gotta get to a save-point before I die.
So, I'ma try to run down...
to the same one that I went to before.
Straight down this hallway.
Blink-blonk.
Nothin' big deal about it. No big deal. No big steez.
No big steez. There's no steez about this.
I'm- I'm not havin' a steez here, you guys steezin'?
I'm not steezin'.
Yeah.
Just like that.
Blamp!
Save.
Got it! Nailed!
Locked in!
BLAMP!
Okay.
*exhales* okay...
Alright, so now that we got this and the Ultimate Navigator.
SCP-049 is right on top of me.
Ffffuuuuuuuck.
Is that the bug?
I think that's the bug.
Yeah, it's the big. It's-
Oh!
Okay.. It's the bug, it's somewhere.
Okay.
Oh! [SCP-]096 is here.
Where's [SCP-]096?
I'ma take off the gas-mask.
'Cause I can't see with it on.
Oh, wha- why's everything get dark when I look at THAT?!
Such bullshit, you know that is bullshit.
Okay, wait. There was another thing in here.
SCP-500.
Whatever that was.
Okay.
SCP-500 is in here.
What is that?
It's not here.
Wait.
"SCP-500 must be stored in a cool... dry place"
"...level 4..."
"...small plastic can..."
"One pill... effectively cures the subject of all diseases within two..."
Oh! This is the pill!
Ooh, okay.
"Get AIDS and then ask permission"
Oh, wow.
So, it's not here though.
So, someone must've taken SCP-500.
I see...
Okay.
So, someone took SCP-500 in the hopes of curing something,
and then [SCP-]096 is here.
Wait, [SCP-]096... [SCP-]096 isn't...
[SCP-]096 is...
[SCP-]096 isn't Billy.
[SCP-]096...
Isn't that mister long-arms?
Isn't that mister grabby-hands?
Isn't that mister don't-look-at-my-face?
Wh- why- why..?
Why is [SCP-]096 here?
Tha-
That...
That- That's- That's not right.
That's not right!
Oh my God, I'm getting closer to it.
*sharp inhale*
Oh my God, [SCP]-096 is on the other side of this door.
Oh, no..
Uh, oh- oh, no.
*door screeches open*
*faint crying*
Oh, no...
That crying!
*door beeps before closing*
The crying- the crying wasn't a person. The crying was [SCP-]096!
*SCP-096 faintly crying*
OOOOH Fuck.
*crying continues*
*skillfully blows wind out of mouth*
Alright, I'm brave.
*door screeches open*
Don't look. Don't look, don't look, don't look.
Don't look at me!
I'm not lookin'!
Not lookin'.
*crying keeps continuing*
OHH!
Whooow!
Uh, Y-Ay-Ay-Ay-Ay-Ay-AY!
I don't know how to not look at ya!
Uh-oh!
Uh-oh..
Uh-Oh.
Uh-oh.
Ooh, no...
OOH, no..
AYY! Whoa!
*whispers*
Fffucking hell!
*quietly*
What the fuuuuck!
♫What the fuu-uck♫
♫What the fuu-Uuu-Uck!♫
♫What the fuuuck!♫
♫What the Fuu-Uck!♫
♫What the FUUuck♫
♫What The Fuuuck!♫
♫Fucking fuck that, and Fuck YOOOOU!♫
END CREDITS:
Publisher: Markiplier
Performed by: Mark Fischbach
Lyrics by: Mark Fischbach
Choreographer: Mark Fischbach
Captionist: Jack Tramp
Special Thanks:
The "Paranormal" /x/ forum of 4chan
SCP Foundation
Joonas Rikkonen a.k.a. Regalis
Third Subvision Studio
SCP-096
and viewers like you
Fuuuucking hell...
Ah, fuck-off with you. Oh!
*ZAP*
Okay, this bad.
I'ma get outta here before Radical Larry gets me.
Alright, this way then I guess.
Fuckin.. Larry bein' a piece of shit.
And that ladys just got zapped to hell.
Okay,
Where am I? (x5)
Oh, that's bad. That's a bad sound.
What is this?
I don't wanna go in there, that's Radical Larry's closet-
No, that's the-
Oh, fuck! What is that?
Ah, fuck. (x4)
Oh, fuck. Ah, what are you?!
The Cowbell?!
Goddammit, Bing-Bong, Ding-Dong!
Bing-bong bring it on!
God, I don't need any of that!
I don't need that right now, I don't need that!
Bing-bong bring it off!
Aww fuck..
Where is the goddamn computer terminal? I need to save like right now.
OOOOOkay, that's I need to clo- Open The Door!
Oh, fuck. (x5)
Where am I?!
Where am I goddammit?!
Here. Go, go, go.
Go, go, go!
Rubber Ducky, Rubber Ducky, I hate you.
Fuck.
FuuUCK.
FUUUCK!
FUUACK!
Aww, fuck. Not this!
Not what I need, ooh, f-
AYF!
*inhales*
MMMMMMMhhhhmmm....
Mh!
MMM!
MMm mmm MMMMM!
Goddammit! Memory access violation. Oh, fuck.
I'm gettin' back in. I'm not stoppin' yet.
Not gonna stoop!
I'm not gonna staaahp!
Fuuuck.
I'm not gonna stop. I'm goin' back in.
Goin' back in..
*exhales*
Pbbht..
Oh, boy.
That did not go well for me.
Tha- That did not go well for me.
That did- that went the opposite of good.
Yeah, I got boned there. I got boned.
I got boned real hard.
There was some serious boning happening to me and I did not like it.
Uhh!
*inhales through clenched teeth*
*Mark-esque exhale*
*inhales through teeth*
*another Mark-esque exhale*
Fluck.
*quick exhale*
Okay.
Gettin' back into it.
Gettin' back into it...
Where am I? I have all my things.
I'm okay.
I don't know how the fuck I'm gonna get past [SCP-]096 again.
But, holy hell.
Here we go.
*annoyed exhale*
I know there are other entrances.
I- I can do both the gas-mask and the Navigator and then see absolutely nothing.
I can't see shit.
There's a door in front of me and I can't fuckin' open it.
Ooooooohm that's 'cause I'm at the thing.
*SCP-096 crying faintly*
*inhales*
*whispers*
Shiiiit.
I'm gonna go this way.
And I'm gonna go left.
This way.
I'm gonna go through the other entrance.
[SCP-]173's around here.
Okay.
Takin' this off.
This back on.
Blink-blonk.
[SCP-]173?
'Kay, [SCP-]173 is nearby.
But very far away, so that's okay.
Why does it say [SCP-]096 is still there?
That's not normal.
[SCP-]096 is still there.
Why?!
Okay, good. He's gone.
Fuck.
Okay, so if I go through here...
I shouldn't have to worry about it as much.
Right?
Okay, good!
Good, good, good.
Okay.
So...
Hey! Whoa, okay. Alright.
That's bad! (x4)
UH!
Fuck, you're never gettin' me a goddamn break guys!
Fuck you guys.
Fuck all you!
Fuck all you to hell and die!
Fuck off.
Fuuhck ohhayoff.
Fuck wayohayioff.
Fuck right off.
Where am I?
Not here.
Fahk!
Go this way.
[SCP-]176. There's no way to cross this bridge now!
Fuuck.
I dunno what the- what am I lookin' at?
Guys, the goddamn containment area.
It's the architect; but, I don't think I can go through here, can I?
I CAN Apparently!
The Fuck! I didn't think this was a thing.
There's a keypad here.
Aw, I don't have an access code.
Aw, no.
I- I don't think I can go through here.
'Cause this thing, it says on my map that it's walled-off anyway. So I don't think that's correct.
So, there's gotta be...
Gotta be something else here.
Fuck.
Okay, I gotta go- I just gotta wait until SCP..
'Til Radical Larry stops chasing me, and then I gotta go around him.
*exhale*
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine, we're fine. Let's go.
Let's go for it.
Let's go for it. (x5)
Let's go.
It this it?
No, that's not it.
Okay...
Here we go.
This is what I'm lookin' for.
I'ma take this off so I can see.
He's not gonna be here, good.
Good, good, good, good, good, okay.
There's the Cowbell! Okay, I'm on the other side of that. That's good to know.
Aight!
So [SCP-]173 is nearby. I'm assuming that he's gonna be in the same place that he was.
Don't do that.
I'ma read this, hang on.
(reading note)
"God in heaven (hell?), I think the wall cracked. Or the floor? Ceiling? I haven't been up top in twelve years,"
"I don't know which edge is top..."
Twelve Years?!
(reading note)
"...When the locks dropped, the security walls released. Each sub-section is sealed now, we're all cut off."
Twelse Years?!
What?!
(reading note)
"...I mean bulge, like a bedsheet with a naughty child underneath..."
What the fffuck are you talkin' about?
(reading note)
"...then just go back down. My teeth are feeling odd."
What?!
*SCP-173 moving*
*metallic noises*
Ay!
Okay..
AH!
Fucking!
What The Fuck?!
(strained)
OOOOOOOOOOOH Fuck!
I'm sti- I'ma keep goin' if it'll load.
Nope, it won't load. I'm gonna keep goin' anyway.
FUUUUuck.
*rough exhale*
I'm goin' again.
We're still doing this.
We're not givin' up on this bullshit.
I'm not givin up on this.
*ready a'f exhale*
I got this.
I got this...
Oof..
Oof! *mouth noise*
*mouth stuff*
*I'm lost. IDK what to call this*
*hungry noises?*
*punch 1*
*punch 2*
*agitated animal noises*
Fuckin' hell.
Goddammit.
That really scared the piss outta me. That was like..
'Cause I looked. I blinked.
It was Fine and then I DIED!
Like what the SHIT happened?!
I don't even know where it came from
I don't know what the fuck was goin' on.
I was at a complete loss.
So what I'ma do.
I'ma risk it with uh..
I'm gonna risk it with [SCP-]096 again.
Am I goin' the right way, no I am Not.
*static*
The fuck was that?
The fuck was that?!
Dafuq was that?!
'Kay, either way, I'm gonna risk it with [SCP-]096 again.
Just gotta..
Look at the ground!
Lookin' at the ground!
I am lookin' at the ground!
I'm Lookin' At The Ground!
Lookin' AAAHT THE GROUND!
Lookin' at the ground..
♫Lookin' at the ground♫
♫Lookin' at the fuck-in' Grooooound!♫
♫Lookin' At The Fuckin' GROUND!♫
END CREDITS:
Publisher: Markiplier
Performed by: Mark Fischbach
Lyrics by: Mark Fischbach
Choreographer: Mark Fischbach
Captionist: Jack Tramp
AH, Fuck It! Just go by!
Go! Go! Go, dude! Hey- GOOO!
GOOOO!
Alright then, okay. I'll go.
Thanks dude. Okay. Alright, bye then.
So Radical Larry's gonna come anytime now.
This lady's gonna get zapped over there.
So, there's no way to go there.
I have to go this way.
Okay.
Alright, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
I mean everything is God-Fuckin' awful, but...
Oh, what is- why is..
..why is that so shimmery?
I don't like the look of that!
That's not good.
I'm gonna open up this and maybe there's a save-point in here.
Fuuck me.
Please tell me there's a save point.
YES!
Yes!
Save.
Save- Oh, don't look at that.
Wait, no. That's not a save-point.
No, I don't need to turn that off.
Stop looking at it!
Okay.
Is there a save-point down here?
I don't think so.
I don't think so. (x3)
I don't think so. (x2)
I don't think so.
This is a save-point though.
*Mark should really get an inhaler noises*
*Mark should really get an exorcism noise*
Fuck.
I don't think you guys know, but I'm like..
I'm not okay right now.
Fuck!
I can only do so much horror at once.
Fuck.
Fuck...
Okay.
Cowbell room.
Fuck.
The cowbell.. No, that's not the cowbell.
(reading note)
"...small teddy bear..."
Uuuhh..
Oh yeah, that's the thing that..
Makes the ear-version of itself or the..
Fuh-okay.
Alright.
Okay, there's Larry. He's right there. That's fine.
'Cause if I go this way..
Blink-blonk.
Where are ya buddy?!
Where are ya friendo?!
You 'round here? Are ya not? Okay.
Oh, Go- noooo.
No, I'm not going in the goddamn elevator.
Okay, I guess I'm just gonna go this way.
'Cause I got nothin' better to do with my life.
'Kay, where are you? Which side are you on?
Which side are you on?
Which side are you on?!
Which side are you on!
Okay.
Alright.
Don't fuck with me.
Okay?
Do Not!
If you're down here..
Don't fuck with me.
Oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck!
Fuck. (x5)
Okay, alright.
Don't- Stop! It's dicking with me.
It's dicking with me to an extreme degree right now!
I'm just- Gobba- Come Back For That.. later!
Later! Oh, God. He's goin' through the floors isn't he?
He's goin' through the walls. (x3)
Okay.
It's fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
Okay, he's done.
I need a save-point.
Oooh fuck, where am I?
[SCP-]106 is nearby, but that's okay- That's Larry.
[SCP-]173 is not nearby.
Okay, good.
Good, good, good.
Kay, what is this?
Okay..
Is that that- That's the heavy containment-zone isn't it?
But I think it's locked down.
Heeey!
How's it goin' again? Can you let me in? Okay, no? Alright then.
So that's the heavy containment-zone, I don't need to go there yet.
Probably all of these are heavy containment-zone entrances.
Okay.
Ah! Here we go, this probably has one.
If I remember.
This is a very weird one.
'Kay.
This a weird one. Yeah I- This a weird one.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, okay.
'Cause it wants to be on somebody.
Oh.
Hi!
How's it goin'?
SCP-035:
Oh, thank God. Someone actually found me.
Thought I was done for a moment there.
SCP-035:
I can get us both safely to the surface.
Just find the control-panel in there and open the chamber doors for me.
I don't wanna do that.
Why- Man, my vision is flipping more and more these days.
SCP-035:
Well, what are you waiting for?
I don't wanna do that.
There's also an access-panel back here, but I don't have the code for it.
SCP-035:
What, do you not... Alright, I admit it, I wouldn't blame you if you don't think I look trustworthy, but please.
I need your help and quickly, the mask has been stuck to my face for some time now, and I think I need medical attention or it might kill me from the inside.
SCP-035:
Just let me out and I can find us an exit in a matter of time.
Yeah, okay. No, I don't think I'ma do that.
Ehhhhhhhhh.....
Yeah, I dont trust him, I don't trust him, I don't trust him. I'm gonna open the door.
SCP-035:
Alright, look. If you still don't think I'm trustworthy enough, there's a locked storage room behind you, you probably noticed that it's guarded with a 4 digit pass code.
Inside is some useful equipment, as well as a pill of SCP-500. The pass code is 5731, got it? 5-7-3-1.
Uh, there's nothing in here.
Um, excuse me, there's nothing in here.
SCP-035:
You see? You can trust me. Now please, just hurry and open the door!
There was nothing in there dude!
Dude, there was nothing in there. There's nothing in here.
Dude, there's a whole lotta dick!
Dude, there's dick in there! I don't trust you!
SCP-035:
You know, the Mobile Task Force will be entering the facility any minute now, guess what they do to stray Class-D's like you?
Guess what they do to Freaks like YoOooOuUUu!
I'm not gonna do it.
I'm gonna hold off for a rainy day. I need to save before I do that.
'Kay, do we have anyone nearby? No, we're good. Okay...
We're in the clear so far.
What is this?
Why are you in there now?
How did you get in there?
I'm not gonna go in there.
No I'm not. Stop turning me around, goddammit!
No.
*guy being [REDACTED] by SCP-096*
Yeah, I'm not gonna go in there.
I can't see shit though.
I'm not gonna go in there.
Yeah, I'm not gonna go in there.
I need to find a computer terminal again.
That was the entrance to that thing.
Is there somethin'' over here?
Whoa, what is this?! What happened?
What happened, where am I?
Whe- what is this?! I don't know this one!
Oh, this is Radical Larry's..
..containment area.
Oh.
Oh, maybe I can, maybe I can
Hello again, maybe I can lock him down.
SsStOOOP!
God, it wants to spin me so much now.
Maybe I could lock him down.
Gimme' a goddamn save-terminal!
Please!
Uh-oh.
I feel like something is here with *static* AY!
Oh, you don't see anything?
Yeah, I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Oh, fuuucking.. Uh-oh.
Hey, buddy.
Don't spin me. For god-sake, don't spin me. Not now!
Not now!
Okay.
Oh, shit. Don't do it. Don't do it. Okay, where am I?
Okay, I need to go further to the right.
I need to find a goddamn computer terminal.
Fuuck! Everything's locked down!
Why is everything locked down? Can I open this?
HUUUH, fuck.
'Kay, it's a four-pronger, so that's nice.
HEEY! WHOOAA! No No No No No!
Fuck You!
*Mark making little horse noises*
Gah! FEYUH- FAH-GIN!
Okay...
Fuck.
Okay, so this is definitely locked down.
Yeah, nothin'.
Okay.
There's another SCP over here.
That's not- what I wanted.
Wait, no. That Wasn't Radical Larry!
THAT's Radical Larry.
Where the fuck is Radical Larry's thing?
I didn't wanna come in here.. yet
Fuck!
What is that over there?
It's nothing.
Shit!
I gotta find..
Goddammit, Larry;
Ya SACK of SHIT, Stop It!
Stop being such an asshole, I just need a computer!
Please, come on, just one. Please, one sweet delicious screen.
To save upon.
To THRUST My DATA Upon!
It's a 5 access-card, not like I need that!
Oh, is this?! No, it's not. It's not! Is it?!
It's Not!
Snot!
Fuck You!
God, fuck this asshole! Where is he comin' from?
Okay, he's comin' from over there.
So, fuck him!
Fuck all that.
Oya-hoya...
Okay.
So, that didn't work out for me.
He's done though.
Where am I?
Jeez..
What is that?!
I've never seen this before!
Where am I?
I don't know where this is.
Wha- I- I can't go forward? What the fuck.
It's like some invisible wall here.
Fuck..
What?!
That makes no sense.
I don't know what's goin' on guys.
I have no idea. I'm so confused.
Goddammit, fuckin' elevator.
UuuaAAAHH Shit No DNA!
Goddammit!
Okay.
I just need a goddamn computer terminal. I haven't saved in ages.
I need something here.
Goddammit [SCP-]173!!!
BILLY!
Fuckin' Billy.
Where is he?
'Kay, he's behind me.
Which is good.
Why?
I see.. whoa.. who..
OH-AH!
Lookin' down at the ground is really cool to do, yeah!
'Kay, where am I?
Not in here! Aw, fuck. Not here.
Shit!
No here, not here.
Go. (x9)
Can't see shit. (x3)
Open the goddamn door, yeah.
Fuck.
'Kay.
Okay.
This was not it. But what IS this then?
Who is...
Who is this other contained.. person?
There's another containment thing in here. Who is-
[SCP-]966? I've never heard of [SCP-]966.
Sentient and violent, but..
I have no idea.
Okay.
I'ma go back this way. I think I can make it past that area where-
[SCP-]096 was.
At least now anyway.
I just wanna be able to get to a save-point.
That's all I want in life right now. That's literally the only thing I want: Is a save-point.
Like, please.
Is he here?
He's not here, okay. So, he's made his way outta here.
Good.
Okay, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
Fuel-pump, on. On.
Okay, that's nice.
That's nice.
Generator.
Okay, good.
No computer-terminal there.
Which is fucking bullshit.
Aww, fuck you.
*horsey-exhale*
Alright.
Fuckin' kill me.
Don't do it, please. I've come so far.
Nearby, dead-end over here.
Okay, please tell me this has- Biohazard??
Oh, fuck.
*quietly*
Oh, fuck. (x4)
Ay, okay. I'll get that in a second.
I just needa make sure..
..fuckin' Billy doesn't come in here.
Nothing happened, Jesus. Okay, I'm gonna put on this suit before I die.
'Cause I have a funny feeling I'm gonna die exposed to this area.
'Kay, I put on the hazmat-suit;
Which is good.
Goddammit!
Well what do I do?
08, I've never heard of [SCP-]008 either.
God, I can't find a fucking computer terminal to save my life!
And it probably will save my life!
'Kay, so- so, Billy's right on-top of me.
*quietly*
Where, where, where, where, where..
Fuck, fuck, fuck!
Where, where, Where, WHERE?!
Where Is He?!
Is he in this room?
'Kay, I'ma put this on.
Whoa, okay. Well the hazmat suit's gonna scare me someday.
Fuck.
He's right here.
Or not, okay.
Oh don't- Doon- Oh, okay. Alright then.
That was dumb of you.
Fuck, don't do that!
Don't do that, don't do that, don't do that, don't do that, don't do that, don't do that, don't do that, don't do that.
So where do I go? I've been everywhere and I can't fucking fi-
I can't fucking find a single terminal.
With which to thrust my data.
I dunno man, I dunno guys. I dunno. I dunno what's goin' on.
'Bein a mega-dick to me!
I've made so much progress and I just haven't been able to find a goddamn save.
I'ma try to make my way back to the only save I've seen last.
Which was the uh..
It was the area where, um..
I'ma put the gas-mask back on.
It was the area through here..
See if there's anything in here. Yep.
Yep, [SCP-]096 is somewhere here.
That- That's okay.
Okay.
While I'm here,
I'll go in here.
Explore this area.
No, not do that.
*icky, scary, spooky noises that made my back tingle while typing this*
Yeah, that's not good.
Yeah, that- that's the opposite of good.
So, [SCP-]173 is nearby.
Be able to see 'em.
There's gotta be a computer room.
I know there was computer room just over here.
Rubber-Ducky over there.
Just fine.
And this was nothing.
Frick!
Don't honk at me!
You squanky bastard.
I don't like none of it!
Goddamn computer.
Please, I'm -
begging you!
Beggin' ya, I'm beggin' ya, I'm beggin' ya, I'm beggin' ya, I'm beggin' ya.
Wasn't there one in here?
There was, wasn't it!
YES! Okay.
Fuckin' Finally! My God.
*deep exhale*
Yeah, why aren't there any save-points?!
Why? Why aren't there any?!
I got no idea, why aren't there any?!
I don't know!
The fuck, man!
Fuck!
Oh, man.
There's just no save-points. Okay!
But I'm in a really good place right now.
Ah, why did I have this in my thing?
I don't need this anymore.
So, I'm in a really good place right now.
I've been playin' for about two hours.
I wanna take a break.
'Cause my voice.. has been really fragile lately.
I don't know. I don't feel sick, which is really weird. But my voice has been really fragile, so.
I'ma take a break right here.
Um, but I definitely want to pick this up again.
Either in a live format, or not, I wanna do this again.
Uh, but in closing I'm gonna read some comments that have uh...
That have been waiting for me.
Uh, so just..
Yeah, thank you guys so much for being here with me.
If you got any comments, I wanna read 'em.
Um..
(reading chat)
Yeah, save-point, yay! I did it, okay.
So, wheew!
Whooo!
Yeah, I don't know what's been goin' on with my voice.
It's be- it's been super weird.
I'm- I'm not sick! Yeah, I'm not sick.
Yeah.
(reading chat)
"Mark is brave!"
I don't think that's- that's brave. No, look..
If you hit F5, saving is only permitted on clickable monitors scattered throughout the series.
I cannot save.
I cannot save..
..unless you're at a computer terminal.
So,
see?
Blap, blap, blap. Pressing F5.
Whew.
So, yeah.
Uh-oh.
That sounds bad, okay.
So, uh, DracoPheonix said,
"Mark, if you wouldn't mind, I'd like to make a gamer's request for more nostalgic purposes and you get diplomatic bragging rights..
..you still don't have to get normal bragging rights."
Oh, "You still HAVE to get normal bragging rights. Like to request to play a game Shinobi for PS2 and it's on PS3."
I don't think I've ever played Shinobi.
For some reason I thought of Shenmue when you said Shinobi. And Shenmue, I loved that game a long time ago.
Let's see. Uh, PewNerfBrawls, "Thank you for everything, third time to do this, I wish. I never get noticed. Please, my Twitter name is [insert inane Twitter name]"
Oh, okay. I see.
Alright, so thank you for that.
And, uh, ChainGunDragon says, "Almost four years ago your Draw My Life inspired me to start my own channel..
..even if no one watches them I've really enjoyed making videos so I kind of owe you that much. So, thank you so much."
Uh, Kevin Aragon says, "I'm so happy to see you playing SCP again..
..You should check out an RPG horror game called Kio's Adventure when you have a chance."
RitaTheGreat said, "Hey Mark, thank you for inspiring me to make my own channel..
..I found you from your Slender Man series. I'm happy I did. Thanks."
Well thank you very much, and congratulations.
MarcidyFlower says, "Hey Mark, thank you so much for everything you've done for us..
..I hope to meet you in person in real life to thank you soon."
And if, uh, you go on the tour maybe you will!
Let's see. Uhh..
Rose Arashi says, "You are one of my absolute favorite YouTubers..
..of all-time. You're the perfect mix of entertaining and sweet..
..Also, if you'd please say 'Rose Arashi'..
..pronounded Air-Ah-She, is best girl! You will be my favorite."
Well thank you very much. I hope I got that corectly. I think I butchered it completely.
Uh, but thank you again.
And then uh -
Gene Nicholas Caress says, "Sunday is my birthday, it's also Easter."
So everyone join me! Remember everyone join me!
Happy birthday to you! And that's it. That's all I can do for now.
But happy birthday.
SwagAwesome says, "You did it. You did it!"
Uh, The Seventh Sword says, "Yo Mark, I started watching you back during Cry of Fear and you've helped me through some very trying times..
..I was inspired to start my own channel. My goal is to one day do a collab. with you if, and when, my channel becomes worthy enough."
Well that's a thing that a lot of people- a lot of people ask. They're like,
"Oh, I hope to do a collab. when my channel becomes worthy enough."
But it's not, it's not a thing of worth. To me, uh, like..
Collabs, I try to do as few as possible and I try to do them with uh -
People that are very close friends of mine.
But what I do do is I play games with people that I've met -
casually.
Uh, that's where I play games. And I feel like you can't become friends with someone if you start out by like,
"Hey! Let's collab!"
And, you know, the only point where you get like -
Collabs that are worth good content is where you play -
Games with people. And I wanna play those games and I wanna do that more. And I wanna like,
Play games with the community, and play multiplayer games that I can play with you guys. I wanna do that a lot more.
Uh, both on-stream, on-video, and not on-stream.
So that's what's important to me. So, uh..
DJ Skit says, "Thank you for everything you do. Can you visit Chicago?"
I'm sure we'll come to Chicago someplace, sometime, because Chicago's like -
The #1 improv. city in the world.
It's where like a lot of improvers go to learn. And where a lot of improvers come up, so..
Given that, I- I'm learning improv. and I love it. I wanna go there.
Uh, Dog-Bite says, "It's so awesome to see more SCP from you. I've been watching you for four years and you've helped me through a lot. Thanks for everything."
Thank you.
Uh -
Kiera Mackenzie says, "Can you please play Dungeon Nightmares 2. Also, been watching since 2013."
I remember I played that, didn't I? Or was that the demo?
Did I only play the demo and the full game got released?
I have no idea.
Gnash Sue said, "Remember the Alamo."
Nixa-Starred Hyena said, "I have actually made my own SCP creature called. Let me know if you see it."
I'll look it up!
Uh, "Do you ever.."
Karellis Denaris says, "Do you ever play games you stopped playing on your channel? Like Stardew Valley for example."
Yeah! Often times when I don't do a series of a game I'll play on my own becuase I think the game's fun.
Uhm.
Kitty Life says, "SCP was the first series I watched from you and I've been watching ever since..
..I'm sure you're so busy, so thank you for taking your time out of your day to do this this. The nostalgia was super overwhelming."
Well obviously, I wanted to this because I thought it would make a great change-up to the day
and like, make this Friday a little special and thank you everybody so much for being here with me.
Uh, The D- The DVR.. The DVR. The fuckin' uhm..
The uh, this video, this stream will be uploaded as a normal video afterwards very soon.
Kay Potter, "Just had mouth-surgery. You're making recovery less awful."
So thank you Kay Potter for watching, appreciate that.
Uh, "Markiplier966 is an SCP that will kill you by destroying your mental state, you need the emerald ring or you'll die."
Advanced001 said that.
Well, that's very important!
I need to find the emerald ring!
I did not know that.
Shit, I'm gonna die.
Frick!
Let's see. JenanDolan, "So glad I caught the stream. Guten tag from Deutschland
Oh, guten tag! Uh -
Guten Abend! If it's evening over there I think.
Let's see. FearCrawler,
"Your videos are my happy-place when not doing scary stories on my channel. Ironic, considering you play a lot of scary games. Fist Bump."
Fist Bump!
Brother Fist!
Let's see. Plarby, "Do you plan on visiting Portland, Oregon?"
I do! I've heard it's a great city.
Uh, YourEnemy said,
"So my dad just got out of heart-surgery and he wanted me to make sure you know that me and him love your videos and he's gonna be watching through your entire recovery."
Well, best of luck to your dad. I hope he gets better very soon. I know that's a rough surgery.
Um. He just got out and if, you know, if he's doin' better then he's on the road to recovery. So, wish him the best from me.
Let's see.
(reading chat)
"Mark you need to use the suit to close the door in the SCP-008 chamber."
So, if I use the suit then close the door.. I was in a bit of a panic! So I wasn't able to think clearly about that one.
Uh, SenguinRose2324 said, "You would kill to play a game casually with you Mark."
I wanna do that! I haven't had time to play a lot of games lately. I haven't even really had time to play Overwatch or whatever, but -
You know, I wanna do- I wanna do a lot more.
So, I will do that very soon.
Uh, Paul Brown said, "Mark I saw you played a game To The Moon; but, I was wondering if you were gonna play A Bird's Story as well."
Is that like a sequel or something to it? Because I'd love to play that!
That sounds good.
Uh, HuskyHickman says, "Have you played Solaris? It's a space game. Check it out."
Okay! I will. And with that -
I am outta time.. I gotta get goin'.
I'm gonna record some Nautica for later today. We're gonna have another video of that.
Uh, comin' very soon. So thank you everybody so much for joining me on this adventure.
I'm gonna be playing more SCP Containment Breach either in the live-stream setting, or in the normal video. So -
Thanks again everybody.
And as always! I will see you...
In the next video!
Buh-bye!
Bye Guys!
Byeee!
Bye! I'm gonna say bye for a good long-time so that I don't cut it off prematurely at the -
when this turns into a normal video. Or otherwise it's GOOSH gonna be me sayin' bye for a while in the video and then it's gonna be weird.
So, bye anyway and GOOD-BYE!
Goodbye guys!
BYEEE!
Goodbye, I'ma- I- B- Goodbye.
Good- Farewell. Fare thee well!
Goodbye, mmmiladies and mmigentles..
mens.